he was the last player to win in
back-to-back years of the US Open and
that was not a threat this year after
Dustin Johnson along with Jason Day and
Rory McIlroy missed the cut at Erin
hills where Brooks Kepco won on Fox he
was part of the coverage we're thrilled
to have back here on the Richardson show
Curtis Strange how are you Curtis you
know rich I'm tired but it's a good
tired it's been a good long week and
always always just best week of the year
for me working a year's open well what
did you make of Aaron Hill so much
conversation going in what's the
conversation going out you know I got to
tell you I think it grew on everybody up
the big hitters feel a bit confined when
they go to the old courses and play the
my dad US Open my US Open made it tight
fairways and you know a lot of rough
around the greens and that type of thing
but that said I mean the game has
changed I'm I try to always keep an open
mind and this was more of a big hitters
course a more modern type you know hilly
rolling terrain big wide fairways let
the guys drive the ball and I like that
most of the guys hit drivers on just
about every hole and that's a good thing
because that's the second most important
part of the game the thing that was
different really different was no rough
around the Greens all of the runoff area
and I must say because of the lay of the
land because the way there's on the golf
course it was pretty good and I was I'm
bar would have to how well they pitched
it off these tight laws because of my
age I don't want to be hitting elonka
clubs all tight lots but you know I
think it was pretty doggone good it was
well accepted by everyone well that said
though I'm just from my perspective as
you mentioned you know your US Open
course your dad's US Open course I was
sitting there watching the big hitters
just smoke it a million miles and as
just as a player I'm thinking to myself
that you know I it's difficult to relate
to it I'll be very honest with you and
I'm yeah I missed the Corey Pavin for
would approach on 18 at Shinnecock where
I see stuff like that I miss seeing
players like that have a shot at the US
Open and I don't know if there's going
to ever be a
player that I was a shot it like that at
the US Open again when we had a guy like
that that I was with the last two days
Brian Harman now certainly was longer
than Corey Pavin of the day but it's all
relative because the ball of the calls
sure it's a wonderful wonderful player
it's first time I'd seen him up close
play 18 holes I've seen him hit balls
and just a wonderful players go happy
just a long successful career on the PGA
Tour but Erin Hills is got him it's just
when you're giving up 40 and 50 yards to
kep and Johnson and Justin Thomas
yesterday on most occasions you can beat
them but you better be damn exact and
you better be Hogan esque and it's tough
to do that especially when the wind blew
yesterday and you have a head of
marvelous termini actually played a good
round yesterday but you know kept could
just beat everybody and in terms of cap
cup how sustainable do you think his
success might be after that first major
win well I think he will continue to
improve he's he's in breeze improved at
every level he's a hard worker if you
look at his history you know he was what
four or five years on the European Tour
he developed over there he got to the
Tour he's developed just just as you
know learn as you go and as long as you
continue to learn he's like that he's a
very quiet guy uh and you know he's the
guy he grew up as a baseball player and
I I'm one that wants my kids to play all
sports corner because I think it
develops all parts of their bodies their
mind everything I think that the part of
him is going to make him damn good in
the future you know what many damn good
yesterday the pressure builds and he
looked like he looks like to me rich
baseball analogy if he's in the batter's
box and somebody throws his head you're
ducking out of the way but it you know
he's a tough guy he's a big strong guy
and and and this this golf is easy
compared to what he did at other sports
that's a that's Curtis Strange for Fox
Sports joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show I don't know if you were on social
media over the weekend Curtis but there
was an interesting back and forth to say
the least
between Steve Elkington and Rory McIlroy
where he accused of being bored
I hear you laughing about I guess you
saw what do you think about that well I
you know I for all the world it's going
to be shocked that I am on Twitter as of
10 days ago so ok it was actually been
quite fun for me because leading up
promote the US Open and given my
thoughts on being out of the course or
whatever and had some nice comments back
it's already already gotten kind of it's
already gotten in the gutter a couple of
times but though you know what I did
learn after a couple of drinks do not
get on your Twitter yet Curtis I got to
be honest with you have I've been on
Twitter since the o.9 draft the NFL
Draft where you know the NFL Network's
like why don't you guys get on Twitter
and social media uh the the the moment
when your thumb hovers over the send
slash 10 button yeah you gotta have a
clear it's like I told my teenage boys
when they started dating and got to
college at guys after you've been
drinking a little bit don't call the
girlfriend nothing good comes out of it
amber not hit Send so anyway to answer
your question I did see some of that and
you have to know elke out Steve
Elkington to realize where he's coming
from he's harmless
he hits 10 sometimes without going
through that filter he's actually
somewhat entertaining but degrading and
a bit annoying to a lot of people so and
what he said about Roy McElroy was a
little bit you know below the kneecaps
below the belt I should say but Roy you
know what I'm seeing Roy and and even
before I got on Twitter account he
responds very well and he's got a wicked
sense of humor in a sarcastic tone that
he plays above he plays the high road
but you know he's playing the low road
yeah sometimes play both roads but yeah
it's been fun but I guess in that regard
though I mean it isn't fair unfair
Curtis to say that when Tiger was
winning championships for wasn't enough
and then five wasn't enough and then six
wasn't enough and it just appears that
that hunger isn't there for Rory and or
any of the extreme
talented players of his generation
that's fair or unfair to say well I
think it's fair in this sense is Tiger
set the bar at many different levels one
is that was the focus and the hunger
Hunger very very selfish
focused and I mean the selfish word in a
good way but it's all about you it's all
about your golf game everything revolves
around you but he took it to the next
level I hate that phrase - oh yeah you
know he just did everything beyond
belief now if Rory McIlroy is to be held
to that standard he's not going to reach
that because Roy has a life he just got
married he likes to do other things
that's all good
there's have to be human out here Roy's
could be the type of players could play
very very well and sometimes not so well
you know he's had some injuries he's
dealing with right now I'll think that
bothered him at all this week but I was
I was surprised I was with Roy the first
day and I was a little surprised at how
poorly he did play but do you know it
happens Curtis Strange couple more
minutes with him here on the Rich Eisen
show calling in from the airport as he's
leaving erin hills which by the way i
think his next level if you don't mind
me using that phrase right here on the
Rich Eisen show so do you think we see
tiger on a weekend professionally again
Curtis I think that's the wrong question
okay let's see Tiger on the weekend with
his kids walk on the street live in a
pain-free normal life and then number
two I'd love to see him back on the
weekend on the golf course but right now
I we all know that he's he's got some
he's got some some you know some bumpy
roads ahead of him and I hope the best
for him as an individual and then then
we'll deal with the golf but I just
don't know I just don't know because um
I've never been there I do know of
people that have you know have some some
abuse issues and you know they can only
beat it if they really want to beat it
and I hope he really wants to beat it
first for his family's sake for his sake
and then once again you know the golf is
later on down the road last one for you
that as we just mentioned with Rory you
know for career majors wondering when
the fifth is coming and then if he's
greedy enough to use the Gordon Gekko
phrase for sixth seventh and eighth with
Spieth and Dustin Johnson and we just
saw a seventh consecutive first time
major winner have we reached parity in
the world of professional golf Curtis
well parity parity at a high level yes
these kids I'm telling you it's
incredible how well they hit the golf
ball
they are truly better they hit it
farther they run faster they jump higher
when you look at a kept guy he's truly
an athlete you know but they're bigger
they're stronger the part of the
equation that doesn't get talked about
when we watch them watch these golf
balls
you know 350 and whatever they're big
human beings kept got looks like it I
want him as I'm drafting as a linebacker
on my team
Dustin Johnson is six four or five and
built like you know just a perfect body
to just swing the stick I don't care
what that's a bit there's but to swing
it I mean you got now you do have the
Brian Harmons and stuff but the big top
players in the world are big strong
individuals now and this is who breaks
out next you know one of them will
Dustin looks like he was on his way and
then fell down the steps but you know
every time we talk about parity in sport
something eventually breaks out and
that's why we love it
Curtis thanks for the time fly safe
let's chat sooner than the last you've
got it enjoyed it thanks rich same here
that's Curtis Strange now a Fox Sports
so Rich Eisen shown weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy